yes my name is ping
[Music]
when Mohan runs off to join the Chinese
army her ancestors send Mu Shu to awaken
the great stone dragon yet much like
Mulan Mu Shu pretends to be something
he's not and marches off to war but if
the stone dragon was really all that
great
why didn't he wake up to save Mulan and
restore honor to the family well turns
out he might have hit the snooze button
on purpose let's jump right into some of
the most convincing theories he didn't
wake up on purpose almost you ever
wanted was to protect the family
unfortunately for him he was strictly in
charge of waking up the ancestors and
ranking his gone when Mu Shu volunteers
to bring Mulan home the ancestors laugh
in his face they remind him that he had
his chance to protect the family and
that his misguidance LED fog to disaster
the elder goes on to say that they'll be
sending a real dragon to retrieve Mulan
Mu Shu is forced to awaken the great
stone dragon and he is obviously not
happy about it but when mu shu rings his
gong nothing happens the great stone
dragon remains intact showing no signs
of life Mu Shu gets impatient and starts
hitting the dragon with his Gong and
then the dragon crumbles although we
love the fact that Mu Shu impersonated
the great stone dragon and took off
after Mulan we're curious to find out
why the Guardian never awakened after
all
Mulan's ancestors woke up seconds after
Mu Shu rang his gong so why should this
one be any different what if the great
stone dragon didn't agree with his
ancestors what if he had faith that mu
shu would help Mulan restore honor to
the family instead of stripping them of
their status since the dragon guardian
is the oldest wisest and most powerful
of all the spirits it just doesn't make
sense that he didn't wake up so we're
thinking that he did this on purpose so
that Mulan would be able to prove just
how powerful she was you are the
craziest man I've ever
Mette and at the same time Musha would
be able to redeem his past mistakes if
the great stone dragon had awakened as
intended he would have gone and
retrieved mulan and that would be at the
end of the story
if mulan hadn't run off to war the Huns
would have invaded the imperial city and
killed the emperor your walls and armies
have fallen they would have overthrown
the Chinese Empire and eventually put an
end to the family so if this theory is
true
the great stone TRACON did the family a
solid by refusing to wake up this theory
is pretty convincing but there's another
one that also manages to ring true he
was too weak to wake up another possible
reason for the great stone dragon
crumbling to a hundred little pieces
might have something to do with his
power levels although mulan's ancestors
view him as the strongest guardian of
all time he might have exhausted his
powers a few decades before Mulan came
around
Mulan's father Faso is known for being a
respected and great warrior li Shang and
Shifu recognized his name immediately
after Mulan introduces herself as
popping son of fazool wazoo fifa's ooh I
didn't know you had a son Mulan's dad
was hurt in battle resulting in him
having a permanent limp so what if the
great stone dragon had been summoned to
protect paws ow when he went off to war
all those years ago some Mulan fans are
convinced that the family is obsessed
with honor due to them having a history
of dishonor
but thanks for foz out being a war hero
honor was restored to the family and
they were allowed to enter the
upper-middle-class the great stone
dragon might have accompanied foz out to
war to help bring honor to them all but
since fahza was injured during battle
it's possible that the great stone
dragon was harmed as well this could
explain why there were small cracks in
the Guardians sculpture and why he
couldn't wake up blue shoes Gong should
have brought him back to life in a
matter of seconds but the stone statue
didn't move a muscle
so what if the great stone dragon was
simply too weak to wake up and go fight
another war who knows the dragon might
need decades or centuries of rest with
awakening again although this theory
totally checks out some fans seem to
believe that the great stone dragon
didn't wake up because he had already
been awakened the great stone dragon was
in mulan all along pylon might not be
the perfect bride or daughter but she's
exactly what china needed when mulan got
back from her disastrous matchmaker
appointment she was at an all-time low
she goes on to sing reflection and while
she does this she places her hand on the
great stone dragon sculpture and pauses
for just a second
soon after the Chinese army marches
through the town and calls her father
off to war Mulan is livid and doesn't
see the point in her father fighting due
to his injuries I will die I know my
place that very night Lu LAN and her
father get into a fight and a storm
passes through and here's where things
get a bit interesting we can see
lightning flash across the great stone
dragon and we soon see Milan nestled
between his legs right then and there
Mulan makes the decision to chop off her
hair and go to war in her father's place
so is it a coincidence that Mulan
visited the great stone dragon twice in
one day
we highly doubt it the reason why moo
shu couldn't wake up the great stone
dragon could be because he had already
been awakened by Mulan perhaps the great
stone dragon entered Mulan's body during
the storm giving her the inner strength
she needed to go off to war save China
and bring honor to the family which one
of these theories makes the most sense
to you sound off in the comments section
below give this video a big thumbs up if
you love Disney Princesses and be sure
to subscribe to the things for more
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows thanks for watching see you next
time
[Music]